und während wir über dieses thema
berichten läuft eine wichtige abstimmung
im bundestag ja da geht es um die
verlängerung der epidemischen lage ich
habe mir einmal hier live in den
bundestag rein es hat sich so haben
unsere reporter und schon berichtet dort
eine art mehrheit schon versammelt im
vorfeld konnte man diese schon ausmachen
müssen wir nur kurz klarstellen da ist
es gerade ziemlich leer wie seine
draußen aber da läuft noch was und das
ist tatsächlich wichtig für ihren für
unseren alltag also im moment sitzt dort
niemand nicht weil kein interesse daran
ist an der korona politik sondern weil
die abgeordneten gerade raus gehen und
eben vor den türen an die stimmen karten
gehen um dort namentlich abzustimmen
über patricia die epidemische lage die
wieder verlängert werden soll um weitere
drei monate und was bedeutet das für uns
alle das wollen wir hier in dieser
sendung auch analysieren denn es
bedeutet dass ein rechtsrahmen
geschaffen wird für weitere verordnungen
dass man also schneller reagieren kann
klar ist aber auch die inzidenz sie soll
nicht mehr der wert sein der da zählt um
dann verordnungen umzusetzen vielmehr
ist man nach der suche auf der suche
nach einem neuen wert er muss erst noch
formuliert werden ganz oben im kurs
stehen die hospitalisierungen also wie
viele menschen 399 sind es derzeit
müssen aufgrund von corona ins
krankenhaus ja für 1 gibt es heute keine
mehrheit das kann man schon voraussagen
bevor das ergebnis dieser namentlichen
abstimmung kommt mit all diesen corona
regeln mit bevormundung und so weiter
einfach schluss zu machen und darüber
wollen wir jetzt diskutieren mit bild
chef julian reichelt an zugeschaltet ist
julian wenn wir das sehen epidemische
lage in diesem ende august mit noch mal
um drei monate verlängert was geht dir
durch den kopf
ja also das was mich ja so besonders
bewegt an dieser debatte die wir da
gerade in den letzten stunden erfolgt
haben ist dass ich durchaus das gefühl
habe dass auf einmal ganz viel möglich
sein soll jetzt zufällig im wahlkampf
was vor wenigen wochen noch als
lebensgefährlich galt früher hat man
immer gesagt im wahlkampf werden die
wähler quasi mit ihrem eigenen geld
gekauft nämlich mit ihrem steuergeld
inzwischen habe ich das gefühl wir
werden nicht mit unserem eigenen geld
gekauft sondern wir werden mit unseren
eigenen grundrechten jetzt zurückgekauft
und quasi an die wahlurne gebracht bis
vor ganz kurzer zeit hieß es dieser
instanz 50 da gebe es überhaupt keine
möglichkeit davon abzuweichen
vor zwei wochen hat sich die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundeskanzlerin getroffen um da einen
neuen wert zu entwickeln es gab keinen
neuen wert weil das robert koch institut
die vier sammelstellen für faxe aus ganz
deutschland da keinen neuen wert
erarbeiten konnte und jetzt auf einmal
wohl in nordrhein westfalen die zahlen
hochschnellen und wo es im wahlkampf
absolut verheerend wäre auf diesen
incidents wert 50 angewiesen zu sein und
dementsprechend dann auf einmal
maßnahmen zu machen wieder irgendwas
dichtzumachen wieder jemand irgendwo
nicht einzulassen ist dass auf einmal
möglich ist es auf einmal möglich diesen
diesen wert abzuschaffen und zu
hinterfragen auf einmal geht es um
krankenhaus zum beleg der
krankenhausbetten und eben nicht mehr
nur um die erkrankung mein gefühl bei
dieser debatte ist
wir werden im wahlkampf mit der
gewährung von freiheiten die unsere
grundrechte sind da auf einmal
genauso gekauft wie früher mit den
wohltaten die es von unseren eigenen
steuergeldern gab und das finde ich als
ja tatsächlich kernerlöse entwicklung
den freiheiten sollten nicht als
manövriermasse im wahlkampf eingesetzt
werden wir hatten julian hier am sonntag
herr armin laschet zu gast er genauso
ein versprechen abgegeben hat der gesagt
hat mit mir wird es keinen weiteren
lockdown mehr geben und jetzt beobachten
will gerade die debatte im bundestag und
dort die verlängerung der epidemischen
lage der schritt schon wieder alle
alarmglocken wie wird der herbst wie
wird der winter schafft man da doch
irgendeine art basis einer art
hintertürchen um dann doch wieder unsere
freiheiten auf andere art und weise mit
anderen wedding einzuschränken ja
natürlich schafft man genau diese
hintertür garantie grade gerade das ist
nicht mal eine hintertür das ist ein
gewaltiges
flug tor das man dann aufmachen und dann
die maßnahmen dadurch strömen lassen
kann uns wird ja immer gesagt man
brauche zwingend diese epidemische
notlage um dann im notfall reagieren zu
können aber der notfall ist inzwischen
nur noch eine sehr theoretische
möglichkeit die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems hat es ohne impfung
nie gegeben und es wird sie auch mit
impfung schon gar nicht geben und
deswegen ist das was da beschworen wird
diese überlastung ein höchst
theoretisches szenario und auf der
grundlage eines höchst theoretischen
szenarios oder zur abwendung eines
vermeintlichen szenarios von dem jeder
weiß dass es nicht kommt kann ich eben
nicht weiterhin einfach nach gutdünken
mehr oder weniger rechte einschränken
und sie dann auch noch großmütig wieder
zu teilen wenn der wahlkampf begonnen
hat und man noch ein bisschen zucker
lief für die wähler braucht unsere
rechte denn keine zuckerl für den
wahlkampf und noch ein ganz
entscheidender punkt wir wissen doch
alle und wir sehen doch alle in unserem
alltag es gibt keine epidemische notlage
in deutschland und ich glaube es ist
brandgefährlich wenn unser parlament
wenn die vertreter dieses landes die
volksvertreter in dem haus über die
steht dem deutschen volke etwas
beschließen die beschließen dass etwas
existiert nämlich die epidemische
notlage von der wir aber alle wissen die
existiert gar nicht wie will man denn
vertrauen in die politik noch mehr
schwächen als die existenz von etwas zu
beschließen wovon jeder weiß dass es
nicht funktioniert nicht existiert dann
sage einmal noch kurz julian wie sollen
wir denn dann damit umgehen jetzt mit
diesen zückerli von denen wir ja ja die
für die wir die wir ganz ganz
selbstverständlich halten also wenn
armin laschet wie hier in der kanzler
nach zu gast ist eben am sonntag und
sagt nie wieder locker und dann ist das
ja nichts wo wir sagen das kommt zum
falschen zeitpunkt sondern das nehmen
wir natürlich also wie sollen wir dann
damit umgehen mit diesen wie du sagst
zuckerl im wahlkampf
ja ich glaube für uns journalisten
sowieso aber auch für die wähler die ja
im moment die möglichkeit haben an
wahlständen zum beispiel sich ihrer
meinung ausdruck zu verleihen müssen
immer wieder deutlich machen das was ihr
uns dazu gesteht ist kein zugeständnis
das gehört uns ihr gebt uns etwas was
ihr uns in großen teilen niemals hätte
weggehen dürfen ja dass wir jetzt
großzügiger weise darüber reden ob
geimpfte
in noch größerer zahl in wie in hamburg
in kneipen oder vielleicht ja sogar in
fußballstadien dürfen dass das ist kein
geschenk von der politik sondern das ist
eine absolute selbstverständlichkeit
wir haben vorhin die abgeordneten im
bundestag gesehen und ich sehe sie damit
maske sitzen und sie sind doch sie sind
ja geimpft das was wir in unserem
parlament gerade sehen ist ein triumph
von unvernunft nämlich voll geimpft sich
dann auch noch auf diese weise zu
schützen damit ja auszudrücken dass wir
ein risiko was de facto gar nicht mehr
existiert immer noch zur grundlage
unseres handelns machen es treibt die
menschen an man merkt es im ganzen land
in den wahnsinn ich war vorhin in
münchen am flughafen und da gilt
innerhalb eines restaurants ffp zwei
masken zwang und außerhalb des
restaurants
kann man die op masken tragen das führt
dazu dass es eine verordnung die der
deutsche staat geschafft hat man steht
an der schwelle zu diesem restaurant
muss seine ffp zwei maske ab er seine
maske abnehmen seine zwei maske
aufsetzen dann geht man mit der ft2
maske ein paar meter zum tisch und da
darf man dann wieder ganz ohne maske
setzen das zeigt doch dass wir uns wie
bei alice im wunderland in einen
absoluten tunnel des wahnsinns begeben
haben und es wäre die aufgabe von
volksvertretern das zu beenden denn ein
allerletzter punkt
wenn die politik davon ausgehen würde
dass das was sie uns ständig erzählt
stimmt dass die menschen in
überwältigendem maße diese maßnahme gut
finden und mittragen
dann würden sie sich doch nicht
ausgerechnet im wahlkampf versuchen
auftreten sagt bild chef julian reichelt
rhein in diesen tunnel des wahnsinns und
er sagt man geht uns hier im wahlkampf
unsere grundrechte zurück wie zucker
levy lück leckerli und ich habe gerade
noch mal werden du gesprochen hast
julian nachgeschaut da das ja auch eine
kritik in richtung armin laschet ist er
am sonntag hier war und ganz klar gesagt
hat mitten im wahlkampf nie wieder
locker und was denn armin laschet
berühmter satz in den monaten zuvor
immer war hat ja mal gesagt corona bitte
nicht zum wahlkampfthema machen also das
hat sich mittlerweile ein bisschen
[Musik]